ask you when prominent Democratic voices
like Morin da and and David aarod and
Van Jones and others are so critical of
Joe Biden and of course he is struggling
cognitively I can't think of in the last
couple of months any appearance that he
has had where he wasn't either mumbling
or bumbling or stumbling or having no
clue where to go where to exit now my
question is do you think in 11 months he
will be their candidate
I personally don't think he makes it
okay I haven't said that I'm saving it
for this big town hall i' never always I
personally don't think
he I think he's in bad shape physically
do you remember when he said I'd like to
take him behind the barn if he took me
behind the barn and I went like
this he I believe he'd fall over I
believe he'd fall over who knows who
know who knows but but it was okay and
by the way it was okay for him to say
that he I'd like to take him be he could
say that and everyone thought it was so
cute if I ever said it they'd say he's a
dictator he's a horrible human being you
know it's a whole double standard we
have in not only in the law but just
about everything else as you know very
well um I personally don't think he
makes it physically I watched him at the
beach he wasn't able to lift a beach
chair which is meant for children to
lift you can lift him like that uh and
mentally I would say he's possibly
equally as bad and maybe worse but I
don't know I will say this he's got
vicious people surrounding him around
that beautiful Oval Office there are
people in that Oval Office that are evil
people bad people smart people Young
Vicious they're Communists and they're
bad who who do you think would replace
him then uh well I saw one person on who
I actually had a very good relationship
with but I'm sure that would end very
quickly I saw him in your debate the
other night and he's slick but he's got
no facts you know he's got no facts uh I
thought he did well considering you're
talking about gav yeah considering that
he didn't have the facts I thought he
did well you know he said we have the
lowest taxes in the country we have the
cleanest streets in the country we have
and I'm saying wait is he talking about
the same place so he'd certainly be one
I guess they say that Kamala would be uh
the one the odds to
be because they say if they didn't give
it to her the African-American vote the
black vote would not go to them and we
just had a poll where I'm at 22 and 25%
with the black vote if we have that we
can call the election over we got to
take a break thank hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else